this is a production of cornell
university
all right so uh welcome to everybody uh
watching live
uh watching recording or listening to us
on the podcast
uh shout out to bed polymer who does a
wonderful job uh
tweeting great pictures that i get to
use uh in these presentations and you
can see right
uh throughout the northeast uh you know
we're getting ready right the turf is
still dormant looks pretty brown
you know temperatures just starting to
come up uh and of course this was the
topic a couple of weeks ago
uh when we had chris sitko on talking
about you know early season
ways of accelerating early season care
um
so with that uh i'll put up a couple
slides here from my pal greg jorvis
uh in in the hudson valley greg is
always so kind to share
some of the wonderfully professional and
progressive things he does down there
at canteen uh in saugerties and greg's
been there
quite a long time and in leadership
positions uh
in the state so big shout out to greg
and here's a little strategy
used for expanding the dugouts right to
give
the athletes a little more room uh
during the spacing time i'm happy to
report
i got my first shot yesterday so in one
more month
many of you may actually start to see me
in person if that works out okay
in the meantime as we start to look at
our turf grass forecast
weather page we have a web page
dedicated to this if for those of you
that might not know that
uh we've had it for about a dozen years
now rt guytano
and director of the climate center puts
all this together that
provides this data that we distribute
regionally
and you can see that you know you go to
the southern part of the region down in
the delmarva area
uh and you're starting to see uh we are
getting about three weeks ahead of
normal
these are days ahead of normal right so
you look up here by the lake and you've
got
rochester and buffalo already surging
ahead
of normal based on the data from uh the
24th
now it does not appear as we talked to
the gulf guys yesterday and and rt
guytano yesterday morning
it does not appear that rainfall is in
the horizon
for anybody in the in the continental
united states except for maybe
uh along the rio grande uh there in
south south
southwestern texas but short of that
everybody is likely to be for the next
week or two
uh above normal temperatures and in this
case below normal
precipitation and above normal
temperatures so
warm and dry which creates a very
interesting condition
for us on sports fields where you know
foot traffic
uh is is generally going to be
moderated a little bit with a little
drier soil moisture now too dry
can be another problem now the soil
since we're talking about soil moisture
soil temperature
still appears to be well into the
you know just in the 40s until you get
into major
metropolitan areas again along the lake
and we're just starting to creep
into the low 50s here in the
metropolitan new york area and
on places on long island now even down
to the south
uh just a couple of days ago they were
just at 53 degrees so just keep in mind
they're just you're just not going to
get a lot of growth
with soil temperatures uh that that that
low
now one of the things we did talk about
again yesterday with the golf guys and
it's good for
you guys in the sports world to
understand this that you know
our pre-emergent herbicides if you're
using these things on sports fields
first off
if you're not using uh pylex or tenacity
um you know the hppd bleaching
herbicides
that allow for over seeding uh you know
you do not want to use a pre-emergent
herbicide where you're going to do some
overseas
because obviously other than those two
most of them are going to restrict any
success you're going to have so you want
to be really careful
as you start to think about these
pre-emergent applications at in
springtime here
uh that you recognize it does limit your
uh
overseeding options and further you know
getting it on this
early with most of those things having a
10
to 12 week life span you will still have
crabgrass pressure
coming later so i would say we have a
little bit of time yet
throughout much of new york state where
we don't need to get our pre-emergent
herbicides because where you look at
where crabgrass is germinating it's
still barely germinating down into the
you know south of the mason-dixon line
if you will
okay now um one of the things we've
noticed is a lot of our low cut fields
fields that we cut fairly low
um are doing a little bit better and you
can see some of the brown tissue we've
seen this a lot with tall fescue turf
left a little bit long through the
winter so here's an advantage of lower
cut
turf it's not something i would suggest
you did
dramatically right now because you're
likely to cause some thinning
and then create opportunities for weeds
to come in but this is in a
normal cool season uh you know
sports turf environment again from greg
jorvis greg
was kind enough again to send an email
yesterday
and and has shown some examples what
he's doing right now in the hudson
valley
you can see these guys pulling the
covers off the turf up here on the top
right
and then a look at what it looks like
where it's not covered
you know compared to where it's covered
so you can see you get a significant
advantage uh
from using these covers in small areas
uh strategically now
you do of course put turf a little bit
at risk here
should we snap down into the 20s and the
teams so
greg knows that there's continued warm
temperatures coming
and so he's comfortable taking this
cover off
now and and getting the the turf
actively growing and able to tolerate
some
some traffic and get some get some
temperatures going into the soil so
on our fields here uh our varsity soccer
fields where we've started to let them
out they're both on the
uh ryegrass poa which you can see
on the left and the right here uh these
ryegrass poe fields that they practice
on
have probably had three or four sessions
on them in the last several days they're
getting about an hour session
a day now uh our coaches are really good
they try to stay away from the goal
mouse for the most part but pretty much
anywhere they're going right now you can
see them digging into the turf and you
can see the cleat marks here
really developing for those of you
watching live or watching on video
you can really see the cleat marks here
and this
is when you start to throw seed this is
when if i had a rye grass field
and that's what this is a rye power
field it used to be blue grass but now
it's transition
we're going to start chucking seed like
crazy because i got bare soil exposed
and as long as i've got that soil
exposed you know i can get some rye
grass in there
and and maybe not germinate right away
but it's there and it's getting cleated
in and if they keep moving the traffic
around
i might be able to at least keep up with
it with warmer temperatures coming
maybe what's there will start to grow
and the seeds that i put down you know
what am i i'm talking about you know two
pounds per thousand
uh in your high traffic areas right now
the other thing as we start talking
about
getting these sports fields ready
obviously that traffic if
we have sand-based systems right so our
systems are draining pretty good
but if not obviously soil management's
going to be a key but again you know you
want to be really careful about how you
start doing these things early in the
season
uh the moisture of your soil how
effective it's going to be
if your turf's already thinning out you
know can you get out there and do any of
these things
is the question but for sure what i
would say
is if you're starting to feel the soil
already becoming firmer and firmer
in places where the traffic is focused
take an aerator out and just do a small
area
you don't have to do the whole field
targeted care
is the way to get the best use out of
your resources right not just say okay
i got to aerate oh i got an area you
know it's two hours it's two guys it's
blah blah blah or maybe even you're
gonna airway
where you throw it on the back of the
tractor and it goes as fast as you can
drive
uh if you feel the whole field needs it
but what we're finding is
if they move the traffic around a little
bit there's only a few areas where i
might even need it
because we're getting them to work with
us now if you can't get them to work
with you
and the gold miles are starting to wear
out um and this is true for synthetic as
well
start checking your depths for synthetic
but for for natural grass systems you
know
get out there and do some target
aerating some target sand top dress
in the meantime and as we turn to the
topic with my friend brian winker who
you know i think i've spent a total of
you know maybe an hour with brian maybe
two hours
of in person uh in our lives i hope we
get the change stat
after the pandemic but i wanted to bring
him here because he's really an expert
in managing some of these things i i see
guys playing around with again
the beauty of twitter and i'm sorry i
didn't uh pay attention to who showed
this but this is just a wonderful
example of using an old-fashioned tool
here
to just start out right get a nice clean
line
on your infield it just it presents such
a different appearance
uh if you got the time now of course you
know any conversation about infield skin
should begin with you know proper
construction
and and maintenance that's based on
standards and you have access to these
astm standards uh for these skin
surfaces
you know but the reality is this is what
a lot of us are confronted with
uh either in the early spring or or at
other times
uh heavy use uh you know if you don't
have the right material
uh in this case i think it's a dura edge
product and you know they're they're
touting how this is a revolutionary
product that you can
work differently and and obviously it's
part of good construction and good
maintenance
but if you have the right material in
there obviously it's going to make a
significant difference but at the end of
the day
um you know we're battling a lot of
these things especially
at school district levels where
pesticide use is restricted right where
you can't just go out and use glyphosate
um you routinely you can use some
there are some burn back products you
can use they're fairly costly they
require
multiple applications and there's the
rigamarole
uh associated with that but this is the
reality of a lot of early spring stuff
so brian that's the first thing i want
to get in your head
the second thing of course is the thing
that the minute i saw it and i spent
like 15 minutes with you my head was
spinning so much we did a podcast
together
and i've been so pleased to see uh the
work munshaw was doing
uh when he was that greg was doing when
he when he was at kentucky and i
i know uh goatley i'm assuming there's a
lot more
projects going on but the incorporation
of kentucky bluegrass
into a bermuda grass system uh taking
advantage of both of them and of course
you and greg have
done a good job in promoting this uh in
social media
uh and and you know you can see in this
case uh greg's talking about
the side that received the traffic
during the month of june
has better quality um and and so you
can see then the non-traffic side here
so
so uh really good traffic tolerance
um and of course i'll i'll wrap it up
with this uh
the youtube channel uh has the stma you
and greg did a
blue muta for beginners and i have to
say it was worth uh the entire watch i
absolutely love this i want to commend
it to everybody
who's interested in this topic and i'll
stop sharing now brian
and you know and just uh turn to you and
say first off
uh big thanks for bringing uh this idea
and concept and
and what a great job you did uh with
greg
highlighting that so let's start with uh
the bermuda thing because i'm sure a lot
of
people isn't like frank okay we're in
new york what are you talking about this
for
but many of them also know i've been
working on a project in brooklyn where
we've been trying to kill about 12 acres
of bermuda grass and we're not very
successful at it
and so these ideas of two grass systems
i don't believe
are far off in fact i'm going to shut up
here
and ask you brian do you remember or did
you ever look into
the work that dave minner and roc assoid
did many years ago when dave was at iowa
uh and and started uh he left missouri
and then went up there and him and rock
were doing these bermuda grass
uh trials in iowa you know planting
bermuda grass in iowa under high traffic
so
welcome to the show uh i gave you a
whole bunch to unpack but let's start
out with how the blue muta idea came to
you
okay thanks for having me today um so
the the idea came from like most people
in the transition zone there's always
issues
with um transitioning back and forth
from
warm season cool season whether you
overseed
a rye grass you know traditional rye
grass
overseed and then you know
the winter kill was was the big thing
was
not knowing every year you know a lot of
years it's a mild winter and it's not an
issue
but on those years that it is an issue
it becomes costly for you and at the
time i worked at a park and wreck
facility um we experienced
winter kill one year and we had to shut
some fields down once the
ryegrass was removed so i played around
a couple years trying to
leave a perennial rye grass in on the
bermuda
and it just it may work in other
climates but in st
louis it doesn't it'll work for 10
months out of the year
and then it dies out so
[Music]
fast forward a couple years um
some of the newer bluegrass is
specifically hgt
introduced to the market and i thought
you know what i'm
i'm going to throw this on on a soccer
field this fall and just
i was just curious to see what it would
look like and
didn't see huge results that first fall
because bluegrass is a little slower out
of the gate than what a rye grass would
be
but that next spring that was one of the
best looking fields that i had
so so now my mind was really going
i sat through stma that winter um there
were a couple talks on phrase mowing
uh there were some talks on uh the guys
up at the maryland sports complex did
uh seating and plunk to play in 35 days
on their soccer field and they were
using the hdt
so i basically put those two concepts
together and
we we phrase mode two soccer fields that
were quick stand bermuda
and then we interceded hgt right into
them
and that's kind of where it started um
dr brad friesenberg from university of
missouri
worked with him on a bunch of different
things he was at my complex
on a fairly regular basis and
i think the comment was this shouldn't
be working
but it is and you should probably start
telling some people what you're
what you've got here so it was
it was by accident but once we figured
out it worked you know then we looked
into it a little bit more and that's
kind of where uh like you said goatley
and munshaw and
and uh friesenberg you know we all kind
of got together at an stma event
yeah and you know there were other
people that we asked and they they all
kind of
said we're crazy and that's a dumb idea
yeah
because they never saw it if they saw it
they would that's one of those seeing
his believing listen
let me ask you a couple of questions
let's unpack this a little bit
because as bermuda grass are coming
north green grass is coming north on the
golf business on teas now
you're seeing them putting it on
south-facing bunker faces as well
so it's not like this is like ridiculous
that bermuda grass is coming further
north
but the risk is pretty high how did the
bermuda grasses come through
this past winter where you guys got you
know smacked around pretty good in the
cold there
uh how have they survived and what can
you say about i'm sure the bermuda
fields you're looking at where you live
so far i've seen a couple fields where
managers have pulled plugs brought them
inside put them in a window
we've got green bermuda there
i think because we were snow covered we
had some insulation
we were fairly mild up until we had that
deep deep freeze for
that two weeks and i mean
some of my customers in southern
missouri we went from negative 23 at a
low
and then a week later they were 73
degrees for their high so
we had a huge swing so
right now we're seeing we're not seeing
the the death that we thought we'd see
yet but bermuda still hasn't
completely woken up so we're probably
still another
month and a half before we really see
the damage there
okay so a couple of things one is um
there's two things i want to talk about
the grasses
one is your continued suggestion
that the uh the bermuda helps the
bluegrass with
heat stressed uh the blue bermuda grip
the bermuda grass helps the bluegrass
with heat stress tolerance
and the bluegrass helps the bermuda
survive some low temperature
kill uh how is i know that's what i
remember us talking about on the podcast
a while ago
uh is that still true are you still
seeing that happen and then
you know the part two question is uh it
was pretty much
bar vet and now maybe we're learning it
might be other bermudas and other
uh grasses as well but let's start out
with the enhanced stress tolerance
to both so so yeah we don't
i don't have the scientific data i guess
it's more
observational but we do see
in the summertime that as that bluegrass
stresses
it essentially reseeds into the canopy
and your field
looks like a bermuda field as it cools
off
that blue grass comes back out and then
through the wintertime obviously having
a darker green
surface you're going to hold more heat
into that canopy so whether it's
5 degrees or 10 degrees you know that i
don't have the
the data on but you can't deny that a
darker surface is going to hold more
heat there
so so that's kind of what we see
um and then yes so hgt was the original
bluegrass that i worked with for years
um
i i love that grass it's very aggressive
it's traffic tolerant heat tower but
it's not the only grass that this system
works with um
obviously munchau who works with
mountain view now we we've
we've worked with 365. that
that was the mix that was in blue muta
at the rose bowl the last couple years
um and there are other blue grasses out
there so i
i i'm always careful to say you know i
i used hvt personally it's a great grass
i know it works in the system i know 365
works in the system
i'm not saying other grasses don't i
just don't have that firsthand
experience
i know dr munshaw when he was at
kentucky had a ton of plots with
different
varieties of bluegrass and he could
probably rattle off
who was good and whose wasn't and so let
me ask you
how far north obviously if goatly's
playing around with the virginia that's
right in our backyard here
is that the furthest north anybody's
been playing around with this
uh this this uh
blue mute yeah i i think
i think that's probably one of the
further north
um i know we've got some in in northern
ohio
um and then we have to move
and then brian we gotta move to the cold
tolerant bermuda is like tahoma
31 lat 36 right yes
tahoma north bridge latitude yes they're
gonna be a little bit more cold tolerant
um so yes going north obviously uh the
bermuda is gonna be the
the biggest limiting factor there and
then going south
um you know that's the one we keep
pushing it
even further and further um i've got
guys in
in norman oklahoma that have got some
some
uh bluegrass put in down there um
so i think the further south i think it
i think the
the range is maybe goes a little bit
further south than it does go north just
because
you know bermuda is just it's it's
limited on how far north it's going to
grow
right now and and obviously the heat
stress tolerance of the bar vet
is uh uh you know really important and
and listen i personally think some of
this has to do with
the rhizomatous network that gets
created underneath
that allows that stability that ryegrass
doesn't give you either right ryegrass
is a bunch type grass it's not
knitting in to the bermuda like the
bluegrass does so i
i just think that's enormously
fascinating and oh you know wanted to
get you on to chat about that
carl are there questions that anybody
had
to this point about blue muta because i
want to go
to the infield skin stuff because i know
that's another pertinent
uh part of our conversation today yeah
you guys covered
actually ben asked the question exactly
what you just asked frank how far
how far north can we go with that sort
of thing so i think you guys covered
that
um now it's and now uh yeah i would love
to hear about the infield skin stuff so
baseball spring training
you know let's let's uh let's hear about
that yeah opening days next week
opening days i think thursday at the
stadium i think they're going to let
you know several thousand into yankee
stadium so we're very happy about that
brian i'm sure as
you're a baseball guy like me and i'm
jonesing for 162 games that thing
that thing they gave us last year was
okay but i need a long
season that i can eat a lot of peanuts
uh in front of so let's
let's uh let's talk about this now
because
um what are you what do you uh
say are the standard things um
guys should be thinking about in the
spring presuming
okay let's presume they didn't really
set it up
exactly how they wanted to in in at the
end of last season so
talk a little bit about how covid played
around for you in the midwest
and then what you've seen the skins go
through uh up until this point
okay so it was kind of all over the
place but
what we did see where a lot of infields
basically get abandoned
for for months at a time so the slide
you showed earlier
that's pretty indicative of what a lot
of infields
looked like so um we did
here in missouri get some fall ball in
so guys
most of them did get cleaned up so if
you uh
hopefully you're not starting with weeds
all over your infield but at this point
if you are
you know um you can do an aggressive
nail drag
try and and get that vegetation off of
that skinned infield
um one of the big things that i always
recommend coming out of winter is where
the freeze and thaw cycle is uh
have managers get a like a two and a
half ton
dual drum roller roll your infield
get it compacted back down
having a positive surface drainage is
is really key no matter what kind of
in-field material you have
if you don't have positive surface
drainage you're going to have water
issues so
we want to make sure that that water
sheets off not necessarily perks
into that infield soil i still see some
some specs on some construction jobs
where they want to put drain tiles in
the skin
i i'm always i recommend they don't do
that
those those drain tiles tend to not
really work they get
silted in and again you want that water
to sheet off
and then um as we talk not only in
fields but
the mound and the plate areas moisture
management
is really the key there um you could buy
the highest end of highest end clay
and put it on your mound and plate but
if you don't have good moisture
and you're not covering those areas
you're really wasting your money so if
you really want to
protect those areas moisture is key
and then same with the infield skin
moistures
is a big one that you want to have that
cleat in
and cleat out on that you don't want it
to be
rock hard i see that too many times
where
whether it's a manager or coach is
afraid to put water on his skinned
infield
and once you show them the proper
moisture and you show them how the ball
bounces
it plays better um and then you know the
guys are sliding it's not like you're
sliding on concrete
those things are all um key as we look
at moisture management
so can you you know i've seen guys um
again let's presume that they're they're
getting them close to in shape
and they you know i think a lot of the
problems we have
uh particularly at the small school
districts where they just you know
they don't have the know-how and and no
one knows how to strategically make it
better
with a little bit of money like just
doing an infield or something and
leaving the outfield
i've seen and and really liked because
we have it here
at our school um synthetic uh
systems all synthetic infield systems uh
with just a mound
as clay even even the batter's box is
synthetic
but assuming that you know are there
some simple things like okay
make sure it's got the weeds out make
sure you get a nail drag and a roll on
it that it's firm
how much after that can i you know then
if you got a little labor
cover those areas because they'll be
really good now
what about conditioners what about
things you can spread on the surface
that might help with holding moisture
because as you saw
you've got the same thing we're heading
into a dry spell
which you know we like in many ways but
in other ways we got the added problem
up here brian i don't think guys have
any irrigation even fired up yet yeah
will conditioner help me manage some of
the moisture in the surface
yes so when we talk conditioners i
always
explain it where that is a it's like a
mulch on your skin
um it should be about a quarter and a
half inch on top
and then when we talk conditioners we
talk calcine which is going to absorb
more
um than what an expanded shale would so
i typically like especially at the high
school level
we'll start the season with a cow sign
because it's going to absorb more water
it's going to hold it there and then as
we get into summer
whether it's a park and wreck or if high
school is using that field in the summer
we'll start to put in an explain
expanded shale because it absorbs
less so it's going to let that water
filter through
and hydrate that that infield skin so
again it's all about that moisture
management so
it's good to kind of have both
conditioners in your
arsenal as you move throughout the
season and and there you go brian that
that is absolutely the perfect way to
end this thing
uh carl questions uh or we're at the
witching hour
i'll i'll take an early minute here and
thank you brian while maybe people
thinking of questions
really appreciate you taking the time uh
it's so great to hear from you
and it's i know you have a wealth of
experience and you know to me or every
like an extension agent in the middle
part of the country because i know
uh you've been very thoughtful about
this for a really long time so big
thanks
for taking the time to join us um carl
we got any questions for brian as we get
out of here
no questions i think uh could you guys
cover it all i put a link to the youtube
stma video with brian
uh and greg that's that's a it's a cool
watch for the blue butter for beginners
um so we'll also put that
uh the link below in the youtube video
as well
um right again 30 minutes fastest 30
minutes of turf thanks to all our live
audience for attending uh thanks for
listening or watching on youtube and
an apple podcast brian thank you again
for joining us uh we'll see you guys
next week this has been a production of
cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu